ん
me
ええええええ
ben
me
car
ni
不不不不不不不不不不不
2 me
me
wh
はございません
ん
やあみんなスズメが遅れたはじめのかすらまあ今日簡単なあ
ねえこちらのレンズです
まあこれはねー
ば簡単に言えば単焦点レンズというもので
安全で僕もカメラには詳しくないんですけど単焦点レンズって何ですか
ません簡単に言えばズレやって来ない[ __ ]レンズのことです
ああそれに万円も払ったんですそうで近し
スズメができないのと引き換えにですねー
すごい
綺麗に母系が採れるという
ロー後テーマからこちらの有機物の
そしてみようと思います
見てこれが今の普通のどっ超たいねこんな感じだよ
あーこれ志社大にちょっと何でもないです
おいこれが今の普通のレンズの総体でレンズを帰ってみようと思います
かっこいいよ
あーちょっと待ってんすげーめっちゃ気だよ
こんな感じでございます
どうですかねさっきと比べて
ボケの関税が全然違うと思うんですけどすごい
こんなんですよ
まぁちょっと離れないとなんて言ったら単相てんだから狭いんですよねやっぱ
空間があったほど
その分なんかを
すごいでしょなんか
受けていくなんていうの振りか距離かボケ感が凄いと思うんで
またねー美香ちぃ動画を撮っていこうと思いますよ
最後に動けな動画愛顧にボケだかなぁ
ということ思うんで
宜しくお願いします
ああああああ
ん
me
出動すか